and like you know when you have I mean
you had major surgery they're like we're
doing this there's a 1% chance that like
this can go wrong this is what they told
me completely he gets he gets his Bello
transplant goes into septic shock uh
codes he did yeah heart stops for 20
minutes your dad's heart stop for 205 20
minutes they do CPR I mean they told me
later they go CPR at another medical
facility or like a EMT or something they
go they would have stopped at like 7 to
12 minutes or something you know like
but they did it for 20 minutes at the
Mayo Clinic
how I mean they just the machine's just
breathing for you and his but his heart
stopped heart stopped and they just keep
trying to revive him they were trying to
revive him for 20 minutes and they
brought him back they brought him back